[Música]
olá a todos pessoal aqui quem fala é o
dar que sejam muito bem vindos a mais um
vídeo e mostrado de que em lake view
kenny eu já tenho estado este ano
passado vocês não durarão por isso vamos
ganhar quilos são completa deste jogo
que saiu há pouco tempo pra cima mas pra
você lembrar um pouco o que é este o
wanjiru anterior balanço da evolução o
bbb público é um assunto para o morro do
machado placa e vamos comer na casa vai
morrer aumente quiser pegar ela não
parece que vou tentar sair só vou tentar
sempre dá pra andar do personagem imagem
nós conseguimos controlar os quatro
personagens e essa foi a única coisa que
ouvi este jogo então bora lá pessoal
explorar as casas e ver o que é que este
leitinho que ninguém tem novo aí vou
ficar com o zé da barwa eu não sei se
consegui entrar aqui nesta casa ou não
ou por 5 x 1 mas quero aqui eu fiquei
todo no meu gol já começa bem já começa
bem eu não posso dar ao pd mulheres tudo
no campo tem que investir mec estão que
acham manter nosso país tenha não serve
pra nada porque ainda não discursou mas
já sabemos que justo na casa tenham
alguém mandou apoio a quem não nem pó
temos sede que entrar não são músicos e
músicas e ver tudo igual.o já tá ficando
noite isso quer fazer o cheirinho já
saiu gente usava essas coisas que
aconteceu eu pisei uma coisa aqui é um
garfo gigante eu posso usar isto espanta
espíritos eu sabia que essa floresta na
mal disfarçada tudo tranquilo fiquem
todos aqui o pé da luz que eu vou
explorar as coisas estavam eu não sei se
já vi essa casa não cair vamos entrar
não ficar irritada a gol um barulho e
até já tem bar é um jogo seguro e rápido
chegaram estragadas e não como disse
manuel vai ficar lenta e não através
para com isso que os têm como foco um
cavalheiro e meng os amigos faziam uma
cuba o que estar bem porque vai embora
gosto da época o brasil nunca pagou o
oovoo o que aconteceu que avancem no
tempo para entrar aqui ou em quarto mas
é que o meu guarda de quim sped anj bela
está uma porta uma porta e visível você
só traz o que há não há nem eu já fiquei
bêbada e agora quero fazer aqui já não
sei o que eu posso fazer isso ai meu
deus saiu na frente
aquilo que sabe que alguém começado aqui
porque porque nunca vou me matar eu
abril até uma porta como é que eu não
tenho aquela porta está fechada
amigos parceiros têm sido aí anda atrás
de mim filho no méier está atrás de mim
não ok não tem como esconder agora
quando é que um busca primeira espera
por mim amigas atua em salvador e não é
por aí que eu tinha não era já só tem
uma personagem adora sair um pouco mais
para um pouco mais de uma hora daqui
também estava ok vamos apanhar uma arma
para matar já saibam lidar com os
pleitos da macumba
antônio não do tom não resultou o
esqueleto da macumba não resultou
embora meu deus eu posso apanhar mas
para uma fui som de toadas do maranhão
já só tem esta personagem o resto morreu
tudo ela está lá em cima eu vou apanhar
agora ela conseguirá esta porta eo natal
a sair de dentro da área que anda ela
entrou e entrou bem próxima ao aeroporto
virá da campanha foi se vai mexer para
não chegar aqui era que deixa o filho da
mãe de tudo o que eu esteja me estão
mortos
remova então é isso pessoal vai ficar
porque construir espero que vocês tenham
estava eu não consegui passar o jogo mas
vamos dar nisso eu nem nos comentários
sua forma de o conseguir passar esta
noite qualquer coisa que eu possa fazer
para matar aqui onde moro e é isso conto
com a vossa ajuda vai de novo bundle
líquido bonito fica meio da próxima
semana
[Música]
sim